man you all right yes yeah oh yeah yeah
it's just my sinuses are acting up yeah
yeah I um I was just you know I was just
thinking about Sheila and you know what
I I am totally over her awesome awesome
that's hey let's get this party started
sure
oh
uh
I forgot to get rid of this picture of
Sheila excuse me hey maybe leave the
sensor so one of us can play
oh he's dancing he's dancing with a
photo is he he's doing he's doing this
about it is he kissing it nice I think
he's kissing it you know what I'm gonna
turn this off because we don't need to
change it and you die
he's under his workout look at this his
fans his pants are coming off oh God
yeah no no no no no no no no no no okay
that's happened oh no no no no is he
he's he is totally on the bed he's
totally flat on the bed okay that well
that's just